[Musique]
voilà un mois tout pile que les
inscriptions pour le service national
universel ont ouvert leurs portes
le principe de semaine à ses jours de
cohésion suivi de deux semaines de
mission d'intérêt général qui
permettront à 25000 jeunes volontaires
de se réunir autour des valeurs de la
république
le lancement du service national
universel mais bien loin du service
militaire d'antan une initiative du
président m'a conquis par ce s est nu
souhaiterait introduire progressivement
la notion d'un service militaire adapté
c'est une rupture franche avec ceux qui
a remplacé le service militaire qui
avait été mise en place en 1798
aujourd'hui certains appellent au retour
de ce service national qui avait pour
avantage d'obliger le mélange le service
militaire c'est la cohésion nationale
alors êtes vous pour ou contre le retour
du service militaire
n'êtes vous pas en compte le retour du
service militaire alors là c'était le
gros gros gros gros truc du jour alors
on a avec nos bruno pomart bien entendu
ce nom patron du raid mon ami également
qui est don sera dans btp ce soir et le
général dominique trinquant merci d'être
avec nous merci général fait de la
maison la nation que j'ai fait je vous
le dis êtes vous pour ou contre le
retour du service militaire y aller pour
partout il ya 2 contre gilles verdez et
guillaume genton voies les moins
sportifs les chéris il paraît que
nicolas années paires ninkov et benjamin
vous êtes fait réformer mais vous êtes
pour leurs hôtes exemple j'ai été
déformés parce que pour des problèmes
psychiques
et ce alors déjà mais moi je voulais pas
du tout faire mon service et des niveaux
je travaillais à l'époque donc et ça ça
me sortaient de ma connexion de
travailler en mode travail
voilà des mois je voulais pas le faire
mais en revanche je l'avais beaucoup
discuté parce que j'ai fait beaucoup de
reportages dans l'armée et c'est vrai
que on a le sentiment que ça fait 1 ça
permet un brassage entre les entre les
différentes jeunesse centre charles
logan de de loin et ceux qui sont voilà
bien établie le trouve vraiment et je
regrette de pas l'avoir fait honnêtement
je peux le dire franchement que c'est
très important de le faire je vous ai
rencontré gros si mon chéri voilà un
vrai que c'est une fiction absolu ce que
dit benjamin l'intégration par le
service militaire n'a jamais fonctionné
on sait bien aujourd'hui on veut
récupérer remettre une sorte de service
civique est une sorte de scoutisme de
kermesse c'est ridicule non armés et les
tranches d'âge qui sont au service
étaient 700 mille jeunes aujourd'hui
l'armée n'a absolument pas de ses
besoins de cinq cent mille jeunes
laisser les jeunes s'intégrer bosser
tranquillement c'est dur pour eux et
allez on va les ennuis avec ça et
comment alors vous êtes pour bon bah oui
gilles verdez dit des bêtises et navré
mais oui j'attends de me dire que gilles
verdez dit n'importe quoi
je sais pas s'il a fait d'armé alors non
non ils n'ont pas voulu de moi une
rancoeur vis-à-vis mais non c'est une
bonne école encore autorisé malin quand
on dise effectivement il y en a qui sont
mis à fumer et à boire bon mais ça c'est
un détail mais le ce que disait benjamin
très justement c'est que le brassage
était important que l'armée les uns ans
d'armée que faisait les jeunes afin que
j'ai fait moi c'était ça cadre et moi
j'étais un peu branleur quand j'étais
jeune ça m'a fait du bien de faire un
anar mais voilà donc c'est quelque chose
d'important et je pense qu'il faudrait
le remettre en place puisqu'une majorité
ici le veulent mais avec une nouvelle
forme à seattle qui décide je pense
qu'en pense le général mais très
sincèrement on entend on va avoir la
victoire d'adam dans un instant juste
d'avoir l'avis d'alain bernard montiel
oui alors moi j'ai fait l'armée j'ai
fait l'armée dans la mire des rg étaient
de la base aérienne de mont-de-marsan
c'était assez formidable j'ai fait
beaucoup de prix sous un soleil à main
j'ai fait beaucoup
bonin cambrioler j'avais déjà un peu
d'argent et vous avec mon frère on avait
acheté cette bagnole à les appuyer
l'équivalent de 2000 euros je me suis il
était grand mais là il fallait la
poussée c'était une triumph spitfire
[Rires]
c'était moi j'ai adoré l'armée j'étais
obligée d'y aller toute façon moi que
j'étais apte et au début j'avoue que
j'ai râlé jaffe mais trois jours à
limoges c'est l angoisse totale
j'ai dû interrompre mes études de droit
c'était très compliqué et en fait ça a
été formidable sauf que j'ai fait
beaucoup de trous parce que je le
voudrais
il faut briser un problème d'autorité et
quand je faisais du trou je me sauvais
une fois que la fusion discipline
partait je me sauvais juste une heure
après lui et je rentrais à 5h du mat
juste compris le principe de l'émission
vous avez une question pourquoi le
service militaire
ma mère elle a fait des confitures
j'étais très content pourquoi vous êtes
content parce qu'aujourd'hui si remis
sur le tapis
voilà donc on le sait a priori ça va il
va y avoir un nouveau service militaire
ou pas alors on a remodelé je pense que
le général en parlera aussi laissé nu le
service national universel c'est la plus
jeune qui quinze jours de d'intégration
je dirais aux règles civiques et que ces
institutionnels et autres
d'ailleurs moi j'étais nommé de
directeur d'un centre dans l'aude il ya
un peu partout en france havas
concernant beaucoup d'enfants et ensuite
vous avez un dispositif qui a été mise
en place par michèle alliot marie qui
étaient les epide qui fonctionne bien
pour les 18-25 ans pour que remettre des
gamins qui sont hors circuit scolaire
etc
et ça fonctionne très bien je pense
qu'il faudrait énormément le développer
et c'est je pense que c'est pour ça que
le alors meyrals je pense que vous êtes
pour ou contre l'aris militaire le
retour du service militaire général vous
êtes contre pourquoi je suis étonné que
son art d'abord je dois dire en
introduction que c'est très impressionné
par tous les panneaux pour avec les
visites pour les militaires merci
beaucoup
ceci étant je crois qu'on mélange de
choses on mélange le service militaire
qui est fait pour former des soldats
pour faire la guerre
c'est un métier et aujourd'hui nous
avons des militaires professionnels dont
on entend parler malheureusement quand
il y en a qui sont
et ailleurs et c'est un vrai métier est
autre chose qui est le service national
dont vous venez de parler qui est la
formation des citoyens blancs et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya 25 ans à peu
près je commandais mon régiment à ce
moment là quand ça a été arrêté ça a été
suspendu le service militaire et on est
passé à des journées de défense c5 et
maintenant on parle du service national
et autant je suis pour le service
national pour la formation des citoyens
pour le j'ai toujours quand le neuf
trois rencontres le 16e on n'a pas perdu
son temps et donc je suis tout à fait
pour ça en revanche militaires nos parce
que militer en forme des soldats le
soldat il passe d armes ces frais de la
guerre et en avant 4 avant la chute du
mur de berlin
on avait les le pacte de varsovie qui
était à une étape du tour de france de
la france donc tous les citoyens étaient
en armes pour le défendre
aujourd'hui on a des militaires
professionnels avec des armements très
sophistiqué qui coûte très cher et donc
je pense que c'est pas le rôle de tous
les citoyens
c'est quelque chose quand j'ai commencé
dès que les appelez moi et quand je
terminais une service militaire de mes
appelé je disais à mes soldats que
j'avais beaucoup de peine de voir partir
parce qu'on avait passé dix mois
ensemble et je leur devais jouer pendant
dix mois
j'ai cherché à faire en sorte que vous
ne soyez pas de la chair à canon et je
suis très triste que vous partiez parce
que je vais recommencer à zéro
en tout cas vos histoires personnelles
sont d'ailleurs plus intéressant merci
j'étais secrétaire des aumôniers ah
ouais c'était extrêmement important et
c'est cadré moynier voilà vous êtes
secrétaire des aumôniers j'étais
secrétaire de mounier c'est pour ça que
c'est une autre armée il parle du
service national qui est très différent
cela dit ça m'a appris beaucoup de
choses alors je regrette pas mais merci
banon mais on continuera donc sur vous
alors oui vraiment en fait j'ai fait le
service national jamais ksm service
national donc c'est quoi la différence
entre service militaire et services avec
la crise est cependant moi j'ai fait ça
ça non mais après je pars la guerre
c'est rigolo non franchement ses manies
terre moi je vous dis je comprends ce
que veut dire le général évidemment mais
ce que ce que recherchait les gens est
ce que recherchent toutes vos
chroniqueurs autour de tables cyril
sergent dans l'armée qui était sans
doute bien des gens c'est que je compte
pas ce que veut dire le général mais je
pense que tout ce que leurs recherches
nous tous autour de la table c'est cette
rigueur ce cas dans l'armée c'est ça
voilà c'est pour ça qu'on fait ce
raccourci je dirais quelque part assuré
vous avez raison mais tonnes à une armée
professionnelle et ce qu'a voulu chirac
effectivement mais je pense qu'on aura
besoin à un moment donné d'un cadrage de
nos populations de jeunes beaucoup plus
clair et je pense au pire les fameux net
ce qu'on appelle les net's et les gamins
qui sont hors circuits scolaires qui
sont aux radars etc
ces gamins il va falloir les prendre en
charge et les seules personnes parce que
j'en utilise moins l'été sûr mais sûr
mais quand ce sont des anciens
légionnaires des anciens policiers
reconnaître est qu'il est dommage de
penser qu'il ya que les militaires qui
puisse donner un cadre rappelle que le
service civil est fait dans l'éducation
juste les syndicats se servir parce
qu'on disait ici sur le plateau et
quelques temps j'ai l'impression tout
cela vous êtes vous dit pour parce que
vous avez l'impression encore que c'est
quelque chose qui va remplacer
l'éducation c'est lui qui m'a lancé
c'est ce que je ressens là c'est en fait
vous êtes vous essayez encore de trouver
un autre truc pour dire tiens on va
essayer d'encadrer les jeunes et de leur
faire faire un truc pour qui alors
qu'ils marchent droit
c'est ce que je ressens il voulait
atterrir une face au service militaire
qu'il fasse service müstair guillaume
genton vous êtes content parce que je
suis choqué je suis choqué j'ai
l'impression qu'elles sont les chefs
faudra pas aller dans cette
ça ne sera pas là oui mais service
militaire c'est quelque chose d'un autre
temps ça fait vingt ans que ça a été
suspendu et pour moi c'est quelque chose
d'archaïque et de limites sexiste pour
les hommes je me suis laissé aller c'est
de parler tous les atouts les hommes
tous les mecs n'ont pas forcément envie
de faire un service militaire ça renvoie
des valeurs qui sont pas forcément
celles de tous les hommes c'est tout il
ya des hommes qui sont pas très à l'aise
d'aller faire un service militaire et
c'est pour ça que c'était suspendu aussi
alors qu'ils fassent ça permet pas de
deux en tout cas de les cadrer mais les
jeunes de s'intégrer parce que je pense
que l'armée du nord est et moi si je me
trompe c'est pas non plus que le combat
yahia du logistique c'est à dire qu'on
parle certainement sa forme des
cuisiniers des conducteurs des
professeurs mais le sport le problème
n'est pas là moyens mais il ya le vrai
débat et qu'on l'aimé revoir il sait
société ces élections nous avait dit bah
oui c'est essayer de faire un brassage
brasse assure essayé en fait vous vous
servez du service militaire pour que les
jeunes s'intègrent entre eux donc que
les jeunes apprennent la vie et pour que
et pour que ça fasse le travail des
parents en fin de bail et moi je pense
exactement le contraire de toi
guillaume parce que je pense en a reçu
cette semaine quoi le maire de trappes a
reçu le maire de poissy
ouais en fait vous ont tous dit la même
chose avec des mots différents ils nous
ont dit qu'ils avaient une ghettoïsation
une ultra violence une délinquance
yao yao qu'une mixité aujourd'hui les
gens sont dans des placards y as connu
deux périodes de trappes
il nous a dit non mais moi ce qu'il nous
a dit non mais il nous a dit quand même
rire avec des jeunes ultra plat des gens
très très bien oui mais toi arrêter de
stigmatiser
moi j'ai il a aussi reconnu que veut
dire qu'il ya pas d amalgame
on va dans le mur a ce qu'il faut si le
met les choses et moi à mon avis le
problème c'est que c'est l'ultra
violence aujourd'hui des jeunes et je
pense qu'ils ont besoin d'être cadré
mais ils ont besoin d'être mélangés vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure le 16 9 3 et
ça c'est très important
moi je vous dire quelque chose moi j'ai
l'impression aussi que vous faites une
fausse idée des jeunes des jeunes de
banlieue comme on dit moi je vais vous
dire 95% mais bien ses films
c'est comme ça en tout ils sont
exceptionnels ils ont qu'une envie c'est
de travailler de rigoler avec leurs
potes deux clichés et ils ont regardé
personne et là c'est vrai qu'elle trouve
moyen stigmatisation mais non c est qu
on se sert de tous pour dire tiens on va
essayer de leur de leur mettre un cadre
et on va essayer sert il de deux de
leurs mots clés laden ils sont pas
besoin de vous leur montrez agile moi je
suis entièrement d'accord avec vous
aimez pendant 15 jours ou un mois on va
les mettre dans des camps on va les
atteindre et ça coûte un argent fou
il va falloir faire des hébergements ça
va sans doute servir vos intérêts que je
restais d'être allongée pas youtube
je n'ai rien les jeunes n'ont pas besoin
de ça mais s'il a le droit de donner son
avis ça fait deux fois qu'il a envie de
s'intégrer ans pas bien sûr fils ian
walsh est d'accord a qui veulent arrêter
de dire que les jeunes sondés wazi d'un
survol d'un service mêlée mais pourquoi
je suis là corning a laissé les laissons
arrêtez arrêtez de taper sur les genoux
nous pourrions certainement vie de jeune
fille s'y arrêter moi je sais parler des
cités et vous prépare les jeunes débat
déjà ça veut tout dire de dire ça
désastre avait déjà énorme s'il vous
plaît personne n'a dit si tu es ici
c'est parce que mes cirilo par la dsa il
ya ces % de jeunes dans notre société
je savais juste trente ans que j'occupe
on est gamin donc c'est clair que je
commence à connaître un peu le sujet
moi j'ai des goûts pour les jeunes qui
viennent qui sont pour certains vraiment
borderline même les éducateurs
spécialisés que ce qu'on appelle la pjj
a du mal à les prendre à charge
il ya des jeunes qui ont besoin d'être
pris en charge et je fais pas une
généralité la belle inutile comme on dit
les jeux avaient pas les disques les
films de 200 mixant pendant un mois moi
j'ai adoré j'ai adoré apprendre à manier
une arme
j'ai adoré mes copines responsabiliser
anciens mais une responsabilisation
c'est un brassage de tout finir il donne
à montier non mais moi quand j'ai connu
mon mari du thé jon hamm antimilitarisme
et chasseurs alpins et bas il y avait
des illettrés dans leur groupe
il y avait des ingénieurs et les
illettrés de la campagne très souvent
parce que vous parlez on parle des vieux
jouets mega des tas de gens des
campagnes pour qui le service militaire
a été quelque chose à présent
ce qu'en pensent les téléspectateurs ont
marre que tu as des as pour à 63,24
faudra drogue